I actually I'm generally pretty
optimistic you know it's it's when I
think about stuff like global warming
and I think about like how screwed up
the political system in this country is
and you know a lot of the poor decisions
were making about about the economy the
government is about you know with
developing policy and things like that
you know it makes me you know it makes
you very pessimistic makes me very
pessimistic I you know makes you like
really frustrated but then you look at
like a lot of the great things that have
happened in spite and mean despite you
know George Bush being a pretty lousy
president you know this there's been
this flourishing online it's almost been
despite everything its own you know if
you look at everything's been going on
with with you know the internet and web
two point I hate to see web two point oh
but you know it's a good shorthand it
seems like there's there's been this
this this this flowering of new ideas
and new platforms and and you know more
people getting involved more people
creating and it being broadening and
reaching more people than it ever did
and you know we still have you know vast
majority of humanity to get online and
to reach but like we're getting there
and it's moving forward and you know I
kind of I guess I ultimately feel like
things do work themselves out and and I
feel like in my own life I've been very
very fortunate where you know even you
know when things like an you know when
things seem like they're falling apart
or not going the way I want them to like
things do tend to work themselves on it
so I try to be i tended I guess I'm
fundamentally optimistic that I think
that we will find solutions for our
problems and then we'll have all sorts
of new problems to deal with like you
know that that my hope is that you know
with global warming that that will find
you know new technologies and to me and
that is you know maybe one of the most
pressing issues you know they are facing
us as a species is how do we deal with
global warming and I'm sort of
optimistic that and maybe overly
optimistic that you know technologies
will emerge that will help us solve
those problems that it's
just about you know getting off oil but
it's about finding new ways to remove
carbon from the atmosphere and to help
you know bring things back into balance
and that someone will well will create
something and there's definitely got to
be the financial incentive to do it
right and that will be able to solve
these problems so I guess I'm
fundamentally optimistic that you know
that we'll figure it out if for no other
reason then I see so many I mean there's
so much creativity in so much
intelligence and you know the Internet
has made it possible for people who are
intelligent or who have who are creative
to actually interact with the rest of
the world now in a ways that they
couldn't before that we're tapping into
so much more like human talent who you
know human capability then we then we
would have been we had we were able to
10 or 15 years ago and so I think when I
look around the world when I look at
like the world the little mini world I
live in and like online you know web you
know online media or whatever that it's
so much so competitive and there's so
many so much innovation and so many
ideas coming out and so many people
trying to outdo each other that it's
hard to imagine you know a species that
that is constantly trying to outdo
itself with innovation isn't going to be
able to solve these problems it's really
just a matter of us always innovating
and always working hard and you know
innovations a word that gets tossed
around a lot but you know it you know
you do see it you know it is happening
and it's happening a lot faster than it
used to and people are evolving and
trying to outdo each other trying to
build better things and I think that's
great